hey what is up everyone axel here for
anime uproar and the jujutsu kaizen
manga has
officially returned after a little over
a month long hiatus
for those who don't know the mangaka
gege akutami
decided to take some time off for health
reasons so i hope he's doing a lot
better now
we know it wasn't anything too serious
but the manga industry can be extremely
demanding and i can imagine it's pretty
easy to get worn out working for it
but for now i want to celebrate the
return of this series by having you
leave your favorite moments of the
jujutsu kaizen series in the comments
down below
thank you guys so much for taking part
in this if you enjoy this video and want
to see more jiu-jitsu kaizen content in
the future including
future chapter reviews be sure to leave
a like and if you're new here or if you
just
haven't subscribed to anime uproar make
this the video you subscribe and be sure
to click that bell
and select all notifications you can
also follow anime uproar on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar or you can
follow myself at excellionyt
of course this video will contain jiu
jitsu kaizen manga spoilers as we are
talking about the latest developments in
the jujutsu kaizen series
so proceed with caution you have been
warned okay it has been a hot minute but
the last few chapters of the manga were
absolutely insane hype we ended on an
extremely powerful set of chapters in
which maya sacrifices her life to allow
maki to inherit her
spirit her will and most importantly
her cursed energy and where this new and
improved maki
slaughters the majority of the zenin
clan it was
a lot and in many ways it seems as
though maki will be the new toji but
we'll have to wait and see
and that brings us to chapter 153
gambling match
we pick up with yuji and the gang
talking to tengen and they're being told
that hakari has become a bookmaker for
gambling matches in the tochigi
prefecture while we haven't
actually met hikari yet we have heard
his name a few times with yuta saying
that when serious
hikari is likely even stronger than him
and with gojo saying that he's a student
who might be able to rival him in the
future which is
crazy to think about that is some really
high praise from two of the strongest
sorcerers in the series
and i've been very curious about hikari
for a long time now
we also learned that despite there being
clear rules against letting
non-sorcerers learn about curses and
jujutsu
these gambling matches are basically the
mma for jujutsu sorcerers and curse
users
however the spectators are regular
people so they have to add some special
rules in the situation
but more or less it's like if hogwarts
had an underground boxing circuit for
muggles to watch
yuji and megumi head over to check
things out and megumi explains that it's
important that no one knows they're
connected to the jujutsu schools
because hikari was suspended and now
he's breaking their laws involving these
fights
as such they are basically like cops in
a room full of robbers
megami isn't really sure if hikari will
work with them because all they really
know about him is that he's
famously kind of a jerk and that he's
extremely strong
and that they need him on their side for
the upcoming events
as they try to walk into the building
they're stopped by this buff bouncer
looking guy and his short co-worker
the buff dude demands that they leave
and pulls back to take a swing
but megami says that they need some
money and they came to fight which stops
the dude's fist
about an inch before it lands then we
have a very direct fight club reference
as the man responds that the first rule
of gambling club is that you don't talk
about gambling club
which raises the obvious question for
the man how did they even find out about
this club
also since we don't have a name for this
guy yet i'm just going to call him tyler
pretty fitting i think anyways megami
bluffs that he learned about the club
from an ex-fighter who acted tough
and offers to take his place since the
other guy went missing they get
permission to join however the
stipulation is that only yuji will be
allowed to fight
since the boss just doesn't like megumi
already this
kinda works out in their favor since
let's be real when we're talking about
fist fights
yuji is probably more suited for that
situation and i want to take a moment to
acknowledge the change of pace here
it is super welcome we just went through
a ton
of heavy moments especially with maki
and the zenins
so coming back to an infiltration
mission that is basically just fight
club
is a great way to simmer things down and
give us a moment to catch our breath
after all the terrifying things we just
saw especially after a month-long break
where maybe the pacing would have
suffered for it yuji is a little bit
nervous about their bluff being pushed a
bit far
however megami deduces that if there are
cursed users here
then there's probably a lot of
reorganizing going on and they're most
likely safe
not to mention he is fairly certain that
hikari
was already watching them through the
security camera so they must be getting
close to finally meeting him
the gambling club is already distrusting
of megami though so they'll have to be
extra careful the problem is that the
culling game starts in just
nine days and time is running out
because of this megami decides that they
need to make a move
tonight they cannot afford to wait but
he does state that at the first sign of
trouble
they're gonna have to leave they need to
play this very quickly but also
very safe we cut ahead to tyler
explaining the rules to yuji
for the fight club i mean for the
gambling club
very different things and the most
important things
are that the customers are enjoying
themselves as a result the main two
rules in each fight
are that firstly the fighters can't use
jujutsu techniques
after all if the customers can't see
what's happening
there's no point in them even coming it
would be a pretty bad show in that case
i think
secondly there's no running allowed you
need to fight where the customers can
see you
furthermore there are also two kinds of
fights
real fights and scripted ones and most
importantly those scripted matches
are written by the boss meaning that if
yuji wants to meet hikari
the most straightforward way for him to
do so is to put on one hell of a show
and speaking of shows it is officially
time for the fight
to begin as we see this parking lot has
been made into a makeshift arena by
removing the ceiling
to allow for people to watch from the
upper floor and it looks like it's gonna
be a hell of a fight for the spectators
as well as one that we can enjoy because
yuji's first match
is going to be against panda panda
obviously is going through his own
things at this time
but at least for this moment he seems to
be pretty well held together
i had never really even contemplated the
idea of yuji fighting panda because
it never really seemed like it would
make sense for it to happen
but now that it's here i'm pretty
excited by it sure they can't use their
curse techniques but these guys are more
or less physical brawlers anyways
so i can imagine that it's going to be a
pretty good match honestly
people begin placing their bets and we
see this girl with star-shaped pupils
talking to hikari but he just seems
bored with the situation
saying that no one wants to watch a man
fight a panda because the outcome
is predetermined and vets with
guaranteed outcomes are just
kinda lame however in reality the fight
is anything but boring the crowd and
announcers are going wild as yuji and
the panda give
everything they have for a short time
however at this same time
panda is explaining that because he and
hikari have history together
there's no question of why he's there
but even so he's still being avoided
they're having this discussion
while putting on the show and it's great
he goes on to say that there's actually
another third year student whose
technique might be a problem
which is interesting i don't think we've
had any information on this extra third
year
at all up until now however what i do
know is that almost every third year
student we've met so far
is a monster so i'm assuming they will
be too
panda sets yuji up for the victory and
yuji sends him flying
immediately drawing the attention of
hikari who just watched this man beat up
a panda
and watch the arena go electric as a
result he calls someone at the arena and
says that yuji will be winning
all of his fights going forward and that
his way of fighting
was very deliberate towards drawing
attention to the fight
hikari is beyond excited to work with
him saying that he could write a whole
book
worth of scripts for this fighter we
also find out the name of the starry
eyed girl who seems to be the other
third year student that panda was
talking about earlier
with her name being hoshi kirara this is
pretty fitting since hoshi means star
and her eyes have stars in them
but either way as the conversation keeps
going we see megami listening in from
the shadows as they talk about how
kirara will be sent to watch him later
since they still don't trust him and
with that the chapter comes to the close
as hikari says that the last time he
felt like this was when his
ex-girlfriend went on a shopping spree
with his credit cards and he had to take
on
installment payments to pay them off
which i mean i don't know about you but
i'm not usually super happy when i've
had a girlfriend do that
so i'm not sure where this guy really
stands in this situation
maybe he just means that he hasn't been
so fired up or passionate
since that happened because yeah i would
be pretty emotional as well
but we'll have to wait and see like i
said that is all for this chapter i am
very curious about how hikari will react
when hearing about the cullen game
does he already know about it what's
going to happen from here
and if he is just told about it by yuji
or megumi will he be interested in
helping or not
when he learns out about the stakes that
are involved on top of
all of that while i am curious about
hikari i think i'm much more
nervous and interested in this other
third-year kirara
who is she what was this technique that
panda was so nervous about
i have a million questions for her since
they just kind of dropped her in from
nowhere and i'm hoping we'll get some
answers soon i think it was honestly a
pretty fun way to come back to jiu-jitsu
kaizen after this hiatus
we left on such a serious and honestly
scary note and i was worried that the
break might make it difficult to
continue on that tense track
but jumping back to a section that is
clearly meant to be more fun
was just a great idea and i think it
paid off really well
but what did you guys think of the
chapter and what do you guys think about
hikari and kirara
really interested to know your thoughts
if you guys enjoyed this video
be sure to leave a like and subscribe to
anime uproar to see
all future content you really do have to
go out of your way to hit that bell
because if you don't select all
notifications we can't guarantee that
youtube will suggest our content to you
it's just how youtube works
that being said you can follow the
channel at anime uproar on twitter and
instagram
or you can follow myself at excellionyt
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible
a special thank you to the absolute mad
lad and disciple of lord twigo himself
alpha sigma and of course all of our the
one tier patrons the ones who stand
above
all other clans ingrada pate heffa
algetal dr cortman the toasted chi
the spike 8227 emperor otaku
spidey life tinel tungsten tarcus
faked buddhist cody hebert and monkey d
quilly and of course i want to thank our
pro hero patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh the
red haired raven
angel cruz anatoly kozitzki very gucci
alicia ochter
bonnie parks hinokami and water joanne
garcia
ted not ted fatboy games corey mcgowan
metal mama deadly saint soul ride slice
and dice
if you're enjoying our videos and feel
like they're adding some level of value
to your life please consider supporting
us over on patreon
even a dollar gives you access to our
patron exclusive discord
and we'll get your name in all of our
videos along with these fantastic people
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time
stay excellent
[Music]
okay